>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> WHOO --
♪ I'M CRYING
I'M SO BAD
'CAUSE I'M AT THE --♪
♪ 1-877 --♪
>> P.O.V. YOU WOKE UP AT TONY'S.
>> HEY, MORNING BEAUTIFUL.
SLEEP OKAY?
GOT BREAKFAST FOR YOU.
COFFEE, FRESH FRUIT.
NAME'S TONY, BY THE WAY.
>> OKAY.
THIS IS DAY 342 OF ME WALKING ON
ALL FOURS.
MAKING MAJOR GAINS.
TESTOSTERONE IS OFF THE CHARTS.
♪ WE'RE ALL SMILES
ON THE SURFACE ♪
♪ BUT WE'RE SAD INSIDE ♪
♪ JUST WHEN SHE -- ♪
♪♪
>> YO, JUST HOOKED UP MY BOY
WITH A FRESH CUT.
HOW YOU FEEL, MAN?
>> I LOVE -- I LOVE IT.
>> HEY, GRANDMA.
YOU EVER MISS GRANDPA?
>> I MISS HIM EVERY DAY.
[ AIRHORN ]
>> OH, GOD!
[ CHIME ]
[ CLICKING ]
>> ACTUALLY, JUST CUSS A LITTLE.
>> FOR REAL?
>> WHAT'RE YOUR FAVORITE CURSE
WORDS?
>> PROBABLY [ BLEEP ] MY
[ BLEEP ][ BLEEP ][ BLEEP ][
BLEEP ]
[ CACKLING ]
>> OKAY, WHAT IS THAT?
A HAIRLESS DOG?
OH, IT'S A MAN.
>> ARE YOU MARRIED?
YES.
ARE YOU A VIRGIN?
WILL YOU EVER HAVE SEGGS?
YES.
WE TRY EVERY DAY.
WILL YOU EVER HAVE SEGGS?
♪ I'M WAITING
WE TRY EVERY DAY.
AT THE COUNTER ♪
♪ I'M WAITING
♪ MAN POUR THE COFFEE ♪
AT THE COUNTER ♪
♪ OH LET'S GO BRANDON ♪
♪ MAN POUR THE COFFEE ♪
>> HEY Y'ALL, GABBY64, I LOVE TO
♪ OH LET'S GO BRANDON ♪
DANCE AND HAVE FUN.
>> HEY Y'ALL, GABBY64, I LOVE TO
I WANT TO ASK Y'ALL IF YOU LIKE
DANCE AND HAVE FUN.
ME BETTER WITH, OR WITHOUT --
I WANT TO ASK Y'ALL IF YOU LIKE
♪♪
ME BETTER WITH, OR WITHOUT --
HERE'S WITH.
♪♪
HERE'S WITHOUT.
AND ONCE MORE WITH.
♪♪
>> Y'ALL KEEP MESSING THESE TWO
UP.
LOOK HERE.
THESE ARE NOT THE SAME.
YOU'RE PISSING ME OFF.
I WILL END YOUR LIFE.
[ BEEP ]
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
SO, HERE IS AN EXPLAINER ON THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
SO --
♪♪
>> I WAS WONDERING IF I COULD BE
YOUR BOYFRIEND MAYBE?
IT'S TONY, BY THE WAY.
>> THAT TIME T.I. TRIED STANDUP
COMEDY.
>> -- AND YOU'LL NEVER GET IT
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AND HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS -- WHAT,
YOU A STRIPPER?
WHAT AM I, A STRIPPER OR
SOMETHING?
>> WHAT?
>> GOD IS GOOD, Y'ALL.
>> WHAT'S UP, GANG.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, WHAT IS IT
AND WHY AM I MAD ABOUT IT?
LET'S TALK.
[ AIRHORN ]
>> NO!
NO!
[ AIRHORN ]
JESUS!
[ BLEEP ]
OH, GOD!
[ AIRHORN ]
I'M GONNA KILL YOU!
♪♪
[ CACKLING ]
>> OKAY, EGGS.
>> NAME'S TONY, BY THE WAY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
TONY CAN GET IT.
>> WHEN YOUR FRIENDS SAY YOU
LOOK EXACTLY LIKE KATHY FROM
"EUPHORIA."
♪♪
>> WHAT ARE YOUR FAVORITE CURSE
WORDS?
>> PROBABLY [ BLEEP ] [ BLEEP ]
[ BLEEP ]
[ CACKLING ]
[ BLEEP ] [ BLEEP ] [ BLEEP ]
>> SO YEAH, BASICALLY I DIDN'T
[ CACKLING ]
GET INTO LAW SCHOOL, AND NEXT
>> SO YEAH, BASICALLY I DIDN'T
THING I KNOW, I'M DOING THIS.
GET INTO LAW SCHOOL, AND NEXT
[ CHIME ]
THING I KNOW, I'M DOING THIS.
>> RAWR.
[ CHIME ]
[ CLICKING ]
>> RAWR.
[ KNOCKING ]
[ CLICKING ]
[ DOOR CREAKS ]
[ KNOCKING ]
>> BUZZ, WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN
[ DOOR CREAKS ]
HERE?
>> BUZZ, WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
HERE?
>> DAD, STAND UP!